هذا هو تردد خلال مجريات الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا اسم كتيبه الصومال هذه
الكتيبه هي كتيبه عسكريه تتكون من متطوعين
من مقاطع
واخرين جاؤوا من مناطق روسيه
سميت الكتيبه بالصومال تشابه لباس افرادها
مع لباس عناصر حركه الشباب الصوماليه
بدايه ظهور
عام
2014 مع بدايه الحركه الانفصاليه في
اوكرانيا في دنيا تحديدا وما عرف ان ذلك
باحداث ميدان
اسس الكتيبه قائد عسكري اسمه ميخائيل تونس
ويطلق عليه لقد جيفي هذا القائد اوتيل عام
2017 في تفجير حدث بمكتبه وسط مدينه
كتيبه الصومال عقيبه حصارها للقوات
الاوكرانيه لاسابيع داخل مطار دونيا
الدولي نهايه عام 2014 ثم السيطره عليه
لاحقا خلال حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا كانت
كتيبه الصومال من طلائع القوات التي
اقتحمت مدينه مريول في مارس اذار الماضي
الى جانب القوات الشيشاني